nos piden graficar f x igual a 2 por el
valor absoluto de x 3-2 y lo que ya
tenemos aquí graficado es igual al valor
absoluto de x así que vamos a hacer esto
usando una serie de transformaciones
ahora vamos a ver si podemos graficar ye
igual al valor absoluto de x 3 en vídeos
anteriores ya hemos hablado sobre esto
en donde reemplazamos nuestra x con una
x + 3 y esto va a desplazar nuestra
gráfica hacia la izquierda tres unidades
pueden ver esto como ye igual al valor
absoluto de x menos menos 3 y todo lo
que restamos de esta x va a ser la
cantidad que desplazamos esta gráfica
por lo que la vamos a desplazar 3
unidades a la izquierda vamos a hacerlo
y después vamos a confirmar que coincide
y tiene sentido vamos a graficar lo si
desplazamos estos tres unidades a la
izquierda se va a ver así todo lo que
teníamos del lado positivo del valor
absoluto tendremos esencialmente ésta
igual a 1 y todo lo que tengamos adentro
del valor absoluto que sea negativo
tendremos una línea con pendiente de
menos 1 que luce así ahora confirmemos
que esto tenga sentido los valores de x
menores a menos 3 tendremos aquí adentro
del valor absoluto va a ser negativo y
luego tomaremos su valor absoluto es por
eso que tenemos esta línea hacia abajo
aquí ahora para los valores de x mayores
al menos 3 cuando le agregamos 3 a éstos
tendremos un valor positivo y es por eso
que tendremos esta línea hacia arriba y
en el punto en el que x es igual a menos
tres tendremos cero adentro del valor
absoluto como no tendríamos antes de
desplazarlo tendríamos el cero dentro
del valor absoluto cuando x es igual a
cero así que espero que esto tenga mayor
sentido para ustedes que cuando
reemplazamos x con x + 3 en este caso y
esto no sólo se cumple para las
funciones que son
absoluto se cumple para todas las
funciones si reemplazamos x con x 3
desplazaremos esta función tres unidades
a la izquierda continuamos con nuestro
problema ahora veamos si podemos
graficar si igualados por el valor
absoluto de x 3 y esto lo que va a hacer
en esencia es multiplicar las pendientes
por un factor de 2 va a estirar
verticalmente con un factor de 2 esta
función así que para los valores de x
mayores a menos 3 en lugar de tener una
pendiente de 1 aquí tendremos una
pendiente de 2 vamos a dibujar esto aquí
tenemos una pendiente de 1 y la vamos a
modificar con una pendiente de 2 y aquí
en lugar de tener la pendiente de menos
1 vamos a tener una pendiente de menos 2
para los valores de x menores a menos 3
esta es la gráfica de igualados por el
valor absoluto de x 3
ahora para llegar a la fx que nos
preguntan tendremos que sumar 2 a todo
esto y ahora en la recta final vamos a
graficar ye igual a 2 por el valor
absoluto de x + 3 + 2 para cualquier
valor de g en esta función naranja ahora
le sumaremos 2 lo que va a desplazarla
verticalmente 2 unidades este punto lo
vamos a desplazar dos unidades arriba
este también y todos los demás puntos
también desplazamos toda la gráfica en
dos unidades por lo que mi función negra
va a lucir así para las x menores a
menos 3 luce así y para las x mayores a
menos 3 luce así esta es nuestra gráfica
de la función fx igualados por el valor
absoluto de x + 32 y pudimos resolver
esto de diferentes maneras
pudimos haber desplazado hacia arriba
primero dos unidades después
multiplicarla por un factor de dos y
después de desplazar las tres unidades
o 1º pudieron multiplicarla por un
factor de 2 primero de desplazar la 2
hacia arriba y después desplazar la 3 a
la izquierda por lo que aquí ocurren 3
transformaciones y pueden realizarlas en
cualquier orden vamos a ponerles código
de colores este de aquí me dice que lo
desplace a la izquierda 3 unidades
este nos dice que es tiremos
verticalmente dos unidades o
esencialmente multiplicar la pendiente
por 2
y esta última parte nos dice desplazar
hacia arriba dos unidades
lo que nos da nuestro resultado final
para fx